my distinct honor and privilege now to
turn the floor over to Professor Gary
Greg we introduced in last hour so I
won't introduce them again but I just
want to say one thing before dr. Greg
comes back up you know the kind of
debate that we heard in the last hour is
exactly the kind of thing that the
Hauenstein Center stands for vigorous
debate no litmus tests we're going to
hear from the left we're going to hear
from the right we're going to hear from
the center but what I want is vigorous
debate answering tough questions
addressing tough questions that's what
the hell and Stein center for
presidential studies is about and I
would urge you to go to our our website
which is changing rapidly every day as
we enlarge it go to all presidents dot
org all presidents org and stay tuned
because you're going to see a lot of
exciting things appear on that website
well with that I'm going to turn the
floor over to dr. Greg
thank you gleaves and thanks to the
Hauenstein Center for hosting this today
in Grand wrap around Valley University
for being such such great hosts today I
want to talk about words I want to talk
about rhetoric I want to talk about
presidential leadership not the way
we've talked about the last hour except
for making snide comments perhaps about
the president's ability the public
speaking what I want to talk about is
leadership symbolic leadership
rhetorical leadership and comparing
franklin delano roosevelt's leadership
following Pearl Harbor the attacks on
Pearl Harbor with the leadership that we
saw from President Bush following the
attacks of 911 gleaves mentioned in his
introduction this morning about the
president's role as chief of state
that's what I want to talk about today a
September 11 2001 President Bush
dictated the following line in his diary
the Pearl Harbor of the 21st century
took place today keep that in mind as we
go through this discussion and the
question and answer period at the end
when I went through FDR's speeches after
Pearl Harbor and I went through very
carefully bushes speeches following 911
I found very important similarities that
I think point us to some roles that we
expect our presidents to play during
times of crisis during times of grief
during times when the American people
needs a central figure to help set the
tone for the country and I also found
some significant differences and we're
going to try to in the limited time we
have to get into all of those maybe the
difference is particularly during a
question-and-answer period there's some
core elements that I found in both
presidents public leader
ship one was the attempt very early on
by both presidents to project what I
call resolve and reassurance I'm going
to talk about that first then I'm going
to talk about how the proposed president
seemed to want to share the public mind
to show the American public they were
sharing in their basic values and
emotions and beliefs and then I want to
talk about the educational role that I
saw both presidents playing first let's
start with resolving reassurance a
people under attack look to leaders it
seems to me to project reassurance to
project project resolve in the face of
threats and chaos we don't like to feel
that all is we're being buffeted around
in a world of blind force Machiavelli
would call Fortuna fortune we don't we
don't like to to feel that we're not in
control and so leaders we expect our
leaders in time of crisis to say I'm in
control here things are going to be okay
we're going to get through this and you
can see that clearly with Bush after
nine eleven you can see it with FDR
after the attacks on Pearl Harbor but
you can see it interestingly with FDR
before Pearl Harbor is actually attacked
by the Japanese FDR for several years
before that attack had mounted an
educational campaign and i'll talk more
about this hopefully if we have time a
little later mounted educational
campaign to tell the American people to
warn us of what was coming to warn the
American people of the threat that
Germany and Japan the Axis powers held
for us but also to say it's going to be
all right we're going to win this we're
going to be okay we're going to be we're
going to get through this his life of a
scholar can be at least seem to the
outside world to be pretty boring
sitting looking at books and manuscripts
and and going nearly blind reading old
old newspapers and things but there's
moments when being a scholar can be lots
of fun and
actually pretty exciting I had one of
those doing this research and the moment
occurred when I ran across a speech a
fireside chat that FDR gave listen to
the the date and it might start to see
the significance on sep tember 11th 1941
FDR gave a fireside chat from the Oval
Office exactly 60 years before bush
would use that same Oval Office to speak
to the nation after the attacks of 911
and he was also speaking of attack an
attack a sneak attack on the United
States back then September 11th 1941
this was an attack German submarine
attack on the US destroyer Greer and one
of the things that he attempted to do in
this was to project resolve to project
reassurance that it was going to be all
right but listen to what he the language
that he uses and in the earlier this is
what makes it so much fun in the earlier
panel we talking about the Bush Doctrine
and preemption and the general tenor of
that was how bad that is I might call
that the Roosevelt doctrine now let's go
back to sep tember 11 1941 and this is
from his fireside chat he counseled the
nation to avoid the fate of other free
peoples who had fallen because they had
and I quote now refused to look the Nazi
danger squarely in the eye until it
actually had them by the throat think
about bush and the argument to go into
Iraq and then he added when you see a
rattlesnake poised to strike you do not
wait until it is struck before you crush
him very similar to what Bush said about
Iraq and the argument for preemption and
again my point to bringing this up is he
attempted to show resolve and
reassurance the end of the speech with
this and with that inner strength that
comes to a free people conscious of
their duty and conscious of the
righteousness of what they do they will
with divine help and guidance stand
their ground against this latest
salt upon their democracy their
sovereignty and their freedom it's going
to be okay we're going to win this thing
after the japanese attacked pearl harbor
on december 7th of course he gave his
famous speech the next day where he
declared before a joint session of
congress the december 7th will be a date
that will live in infamy but what other
things he does in that speech is again
to show that he is in charge that he's
confident that america is going to win
one of his lines early in the very short
address actually was as
commander-in-chief of the army and navy
I have directed all measures to be taken
for defense he's in control things are
being done i quote a little couple of
sentences here now no matter how long it
may take us to overcome this
premeditated invasion the American
people in their righteous might will win
through to absolute victory I believe
that I interpret the will of Congress
and the people when I assert that we
will not only defend ourselves to the
uttermost but will make it very certain
that this form of treachery shall never
again endanger us with confidence in our
armed forces with the unbounding
determination of our people we will gain
the inevitable triumph so help us God
fash flash forward now to 2001 Bush
faced and gleaves to mention this
earlier today the bush faced the
challenge unknown to FDR and that
challenge was finding out about the
attacks and remember how he found out
Gleave said this morning he was talking
to second graders at the armagh booker
elementary school in florida the
unforgiving cameras were there the
reporters were there and remember Andy
card leaned over to him whispered in his
ear this sentence a second plane hit the
second tower America is under attack and
the president was faced with the
situation what does he do at that point
does he get up and go America
under attack right does he get up and
leave does he get on Air Force One does
he convene a cabinet meeting immediately
what's happens in this and what's he do
nothing he just sits there he sits there
and listens to the second graders
complete the reading lesson and then
only when that lessons over then he gets
up calmly and leaves the room and that's
interesting it seems to me because it's
sort of a symbolic leadership that he
that he seemed to be trying to convey in
his very body language FDR didn't have
that handicap FDR found out about Pearl
Harbor in the White House would that
have made a difference I don't know but
I did run across a note by Frank Knox
who was secretary of the Navy it would
visited FDR on December seventh and he
said this this is how he recorded that
moment he said he found FDR quote seated
at his desk he was as white as a sheet
he was visibly shaken knock said and
then he added I think he expected to get
hit but he did not expect to get hurt
well what we saw of FDR was then the
next day very calm resolute strong well
prepared Bush didn't have that advantage
and so you I think in the in the
considering the circumstances he did
pretty good you can see his are if you
look at that again i watch this all very
closely to see his eyes dart around and
he's he's a bit distant a little a
little shocked but nonetheless
considering everything he's pretty calm
and then he goes into the back room and
he takes out his Sharpie pen he carries
a sharpie pen if guess it's not an
endorsement for television but he
carries a sharpie pen with him all the
time and he wrote those first few were
first few sentences that he said with
his Sharpie pen in the back room when
when he came out and later on he told a
journalist about this event he said this
I had to convince myself to be calm and
resolute as possible because I know
people were watching seem to be he knew
what was going on in that circumstances
we've already talked this morning a bit
about how he flew then to Barksdale Air
Force Base and land
there and if you look at what happened
in Air Force One and some of that stuff
available now the notes that were taken
on Air Force One it's really the
president's idea to go down and why
because he says this is a quote from
notes taken on Air Force One I think
it's important for people to see the
government is functioning because the TV
shows our nation has been blasted and
bombed the government is not chaotic
it's functioning smoothly and so he goes
down and can argue whether it does a
good job in that second address it barks
to the Air Force Base in Louisiana but
nonetheless he's there he then gets
criticism for flying all around the
western part of the United States of
course and I think it's particularly
it's one of the anchors Peter Jennings
maybe that that criticizes him for sort
of flying around fleeing around the
western part of the United States and
again if you look at the the notes that
were taken on Air Force One he seems to
predict that but that's exactly what's
happening he said and I quote he told a
secret service agent the American people
want to know where their dang president
is and later when the Secret Service
said what he could convince him to get
back to Andrews Air Force Base to go
back to Washington they wanted him to
take a limousine or take a motorcade
from Andrews Air Force Base to the White
House and secretly and get through is it
much safer away than flying in that low
you know low landing helicopter the
President Bush told The Secret Service
this and I quote I'm landing on the
South Lawn South Lawn in marine one
people want to see me land in the South
Lawn and go into the White House and go
into the Oval Office okay it seemed to
me understood that we expect our leaders
to see them unbowed in charge safe and
we saw the same with with FDR and Bush
both in the rhetoric and in their in
their actions secondly let me go to a
point about sharing the public mind or
representing the public mind if you will
representing but what is representing is
representing
American people seem to expect the men
who hold our highest office to reflect
our values and our most profoundly felt
emotions FDR again had an advantage on
this point it seems to me because when
the Japanese attacked Pearl Harbor in
December of two thousand of 1941 he had
led the American people through the
Great Depression we understood we of
course I wasn't enough to be around then
we the American people understood that
he was one with us he understood our
pain he understood what we were going
through he understood our values and our
beliefs and was with us and so when the
attacks of Pearl Harbor happened it's
not that dramatic of a change it seems
to me it is a very dramatic change with
george w bush and just go back and think
about those few months in office first
few months he was only a month office
for eight months he had been considered
by some at least being not not a
legitimate president all the problems we
had in Florida and all that kind of
stuff he had been painted by his critics
as being a only concern with the rich
because of his tax cut if you remember
what's he doing August of 2001 something
unprecedented for recent president
certainly compared to Clinton he takes a
vacation another vacay she takes a
month-long vacation which goes away for
a month takes all kinds of criticism
that's right before the attacks and so
the change is really fairly dynamic with
dramatic with with Bush let's go back to
FDR though and start there for years as
i said earlier FDR i've been waging a
campaign to educate the American public
and to build support for a war against
the Axis powers he had not done not been
very successful in that if you look at
the public figures as I have the public
polling numbers he had moved the public
somewhat to an understanding that we
needed to be in this war but by no means
a majority considerable amount of the
public was isolationist considered him a
warmonger considering trying to get in
this war to build his own
power much of it you see the same
language used today guess president bush
but what Pearl Harbor did was give FDR
the chance to bind it with the American
public in the public's mind they were
won the war was no longer an abstraction
it was a reality well felt by the
American people in that december eight
the dress he said the people the united
states have already formed their
opinions and well understand the
implications of the very life and safety
of our nation you can ask him 24 hours
how he knows that but he knows that
because that's he know he feels the
American people he knows the American
people and we're a tax sneak attack like
that he knows what we're feeling and
it's the same as he's feeling and and he
went on to say that our the American
people's quote righteous might will win
this will prevail during his radio
address two days later which was
December ninth he said he claimed no
person no honest person today or a
thousand years hence will be able to
suppress a sense of indignation and
horror he was feeling it the American
people were feeling it I deeply feel he
said the anxiety of all the families of
the men of our armed forces and the
relatives of people in cities which have
been bond bombed he uses what we call
the Royal we we the American people us
he is one with them consider this lot
this a couple of sentences from his
State of the Union address which is
january six 1942 the act of Japan at
Pearl Harbor was intended to stun us to
terrify us the plan has failed in its
purpose we have not been stunned we have
not been terrified or confused and he
goes on in that kind of of language fast
forward now to 2001 and I think this is
if you have to look at a central element
in bushes transform
relationship with the American people
it's this aspect of sharing the public
mind sharing the public values and
beliefs not everyone of course he would
continue to have detractors but it seems
to me he gave voice to a very large
public that was anguished that was
prayerful that was then emboldened and
resolute demanding justice and he seemed
to feel all those same emotions it seems
to me on december or on September the
11th that evening at the oval office
this is another interesting quirk of
history is he sat at these very same
desk and not only the those two speeches
that i mentioned FDR and bush occur in
the same room they occurred the same
desk and that desk is made but from the
Timbers of a ship called the HMS
resolute all comes back at that desk he
expressed what he's called the quote
disbelief terrible sadness and quiet
unyielding anger that he had detected
being taking part happening in the
American the American psyche the classic
moment of course as you all know in this
is the moment when he's at the World
Trade Center and he's on at Ground Zero
and he's got his arm around the the
firefighter and he's got the
malfunctioning bullhorn this is a very
slick White House but in that case they
got a bad bullhorn which worked out to
his advantage because he tried to speak
to them remember they couldn't hear him
and so they're yelling they can't hear
you and then he says which is not
actually elegant but in the moment it
became a rallying cry and you saw this
on signs and and bumper stickers and I
know in Louisville there was a printer
that came around and did this big poster
with these words on with the flag and
stuff and just gave out posters I can
hear you the rest of the world hears you
and the people who knocked down these
buildings will hear all of us soon and
then the chants start USA USA USA
Jonathan alter
they're jonathan alter he is a Newsweek
reporter and he instantly at that moment
turned to someone next to him and said
that this is a turning point in history
a turning point in history and whether
it's a turning point in history or not
it certainly was a turning point in the
Bush presidency and what he did with
within his that kind of language in the
language that we heard from him in days
to come it seems to me as he built trust
with the American people and built trust
in such a way that even with a delayed
military response even with going out
now two years and now the polling
numbers are changing so let's say a year
and a half without Osama bin Laden Cod
etc remained enormously historically
historically popular and Bush seemed to
understand that himself he told
journalists bill Sammon in retrospect he
said my quote I guess that's what
America appreciated I was expressing
their sentiments America was hot and we
were sad we cried now presidential
leadership has to be mount more than
representing the public mind however
representing our views and values
presidential leadership has to be about
teaching as well it seems to me FDR
himself called the presidency and i
quote pre-eminently a place of moral
leadership that's a very famous quote
from FDR but what's less famous is what
he added to that that no one talks about
so he called a pre-eminently a place of
moral leadership and he added that and I
quote all our great presidents were
leaders of thought not action the
leaders of thought at times when certain
historic ideas in the life of the nation
had to be clarified the attacks of the
of the Japanese at Pearl Harbor Pearl
Harbor and the attacks of the terrorists
on 911 gave both Bush and FDR a chance
to really be teachers to the American
public it seems to me
no deal with on several aspects as many
as i have time to today on this sort of
teaching function because i think it's
important number one let's talk about
how they both attempted to define the
enemy which seemed to me important
defining the enemy is a dress on
december eight that is that famous
address we talked about he called the
japanese enemy deceitful and trick and
tricky and called the attacks unprovoked
and dastardly what's usually forgotten
though and i mentioned this before is
almost no one realizes no one remembers
that he did a very important address on
december night the fireside address and
in fact fireside chat and this was his
this was his idea his aides wanted him
to do a long address before congress
much like bush did on September 20th he
said no he needs a short address to set
the tone and then the next night i'll
come back the american people and even
say do the teaching function but that's
what that's how I'm categorizing it
today and that's what that second dress
is really about in it he demonizes the
Japanese and this will be kind of
surprising perhaps to some of you for
how really harsh his rhetoric is and I
argue much harsher than actually George
Bush's was he called the attacks
criminal he said they were a climax of a
decade of international immorality he
called the axis nations powerful and
resourceful gangsters he said not only
must the shame of the Japanese treachery
be wiped out but the sources of
international brutality educating on the
scope of this war wherever they exist
must be absolutely and finally broken in
a state of the union address remember
Bush got into trouble for in the state
of the union address calling the axis of
evil using that phrase in his state
bushes or FDR state of the union address
he called the Japanese cold and
calculated killers I read two excerpts
from that speech we must not underrate
the enemy he is powerful and cunning and
cruel and ruthless
he will stop at nothing that gives him a
chance to kill and destroy he has
trained his people to believe that the
highest perfection is achieved by waging
war for many years he was prepared for
this very conflict planning and plotting
and training and arming and fighting and
then he pits the what's this war about
he says this war is about in defending
freedom democracy family common decency
and humanity and then again to the
modern ear this is a pretty radical
language and can imagine Bush using it
he focused the war then as a battle
between religion and irreligion and
here's what he said the world is too
small to provide adequate living room
for both Hitler and God in proof of that
the Nazis have now announced their plan
for invoice enforcing their new German
pagan religion all over the world a plan
by which the Holy Bible and the cross of
mercy would be displaced by mine come
from the swastika and the naked sword no
mincing words with FDR here now
fast-forward to 2001's peaches and I
assume these are all on your mind and so
I just throw out the words you know
wanted dead or alive evil calling bin
Laden the evil one calling them cowards
and then all the debate we saw a little
bit of it this morning and whether you
know do you call this you hail it as
moral clarity finally in the President
or do you say this is reckless infantile
sort of rhetoric I don't want to focus
on that right now we can talk about it
may be a question and answer but what I
want to focus on is another aspect of
the bush that's that's clear when you
look at the bushes speeches and his
symbolic symbolic actions in that he was
attempting very clearly to avoid a
problem that is AIDS at least say that
he and the White House understood from
World War two and that is to make sure
that Islamic people's the united states
were not treated as the japanese were in
World War two and how
do that several several ways let me tell
you go through a few quickly he included
an Islamic cleric remember at the
national prayer service he went into the
Islamic what largest Islamic Center in
Washington remember when that happened
he took his shoes off and he went in and
he read from the Quran and he declared
the face of Terror is not the true faith
of Islam this is teaching and then he
said Islam is peace these terrorists
don't represent peace they represent
evil and war he hosted an iftar dinner
at the White House to begin the Muslim
holy month of Ramadan in his famous
September 20th address before the joint
session of Congress he separated the
terrorists from Islam by saying and I
quote that the terrorist practice a
fringe form of Islamic extremism that
has been rejected by Muslim scholars and
the vast majority of Muslim clerics and
then he spoke to the world he spoke to
adherence of Islam Arab countries around
the world but also invite you to imagine
I think it was he was speaking back to
us I quote a few sentences here we
respect your faith it's practiced freely
by many millions of Americans and by
millions more in countries that America
counts as friends its teachings are good
and peaceful and those who commit evil
in the name of Allah blaspheme the name
of Allah the terrorists are traitors to
their own faith trying in effect the
hijack Islam itself the enemy of America
is not our many Muslim friends it's not
our many Arab friends our enemy is a
radical network of terrorists and every
government that supports them he was not
only defining who the enemy was but
defining who the enemy was not now we
can ask the question did FDR do that and
the answer is actually what I found is
yes he did to a very small degree but I
did find some speeches some minor
speeches where when when word had come
to him that immigrants were being
mistreated around the
not given jobs being fired that kind of
stuff that he did give speeches where he
where he says you know this is a bad
thing this doesn't help America let's
stop doing it I would have to wrap up in
just a second so let me let me say well
just focus on on one more and that is
preparing the nation for war president's
role in this educational role of
preparing the nation for war on december
nine that famous not famous but should
be famous addressed by FDR that i
mentioned one of the first things that
he does is invite all the american
people and i quote every single man
woman and child to be part of the war to
discuss and i quote the defeats and the
victories the changing fortunes of war
together and he told the American people
to quote reject all rumors and they did
an interesting thing that I found I
can't imagine again a present doing this
today but he spoke to journalists and he
said this to journalists that you as
journalists having when I quote a most
grave responsibility to the nation get
his teaching preparing for the war and
that they have the journalists have no
right in the ethics of patriotism to
deal out unconfirmed reports in such a
way as to make people believe that they
are the truth journalists would not be
exempted from what he thought to be the
responsibilities of every American and
he says every citizen in every walk of
life shares the same responsibility the
live of our soldiers and our sailors the
whole future of the nation depend upon
the manner in which each and every one
of us fulfills this obligation to our
country he then went on in a very
detailed way and very protracted way to
lay out what this war would be like that
this war would be long that this war
would be hard that sacrifices would have
to be would have to be made one point
during the speech is this line on the
road ahead
hard work grueling work day and night
every hour every minute he's calling for
sacrifice mrs. leaves will appreciate
this being an old wordsmith as he was he
doesn't want to talk about sacrifice
though bad word I guess sacrifice so
what if what's FDR do he changes
sacrifice what we would understand to be
sacrificed into privileged and he says
the United States does not consider it a
sacrifice to do all one can to give
one's best to our nation when the nation
is fighting for its existence and its
future life rather than sacrifice such
difficulties he said would be a
privilege it's not a sacrifice for any
man old or young to be in the army or
the Navy of the United States rather it
is a privilege it is not a sacrifice for
the industrialist or the wage-earner the
farmer or the shopkeeper the train
mentor the doctor to pay more taxes to
buy more bonds to forego extra profits
to work longer or harder at the task of
which he is best fitted rather it is a
privilege it is not a sacrifice to do
without many things in which we are
accustomed if the national defense calls
for doing without it now this is
something when we fast-forward a 2001 we
can ask the question is did bush miss
this opportunity as some some set and
I'll leave left you're thinking about it
but if you look at his rhetoric his
rhetoric Rios about normalcy right it
wasn't about sacrifice it was about take
your vacations get on the planes fly
again go back to work everything is
going to be okay hug your kids and all
that kind of stuff but it was a rhetoric
of normalcy and so you can ask the
question did he miss a moment when he
could have called us to hire service
perhaps but what he does do and what he
was the new york times on September 19th
criticized him for not doing the new
york times on September 19th in the lead
editorial said that he was quote
inflating expectations and then went on
this line the hotter the red
kids now their claim is too too hot to
bellicose too angry the heart of the
President Bush will find it later for
his better judgment if his better
judgment winds up telling him to delay
action or to concentrate for a while and
diplomatic and economic sanctions rather
than military force as I went through
these speeches though very carefully did
them what you find is a very balanced
rhetoric I think we remember the
warmongering stuff we remember that but
do we remember all the what I call us
with the softer side of Sears of his
leadership do we remember his his
setting up the fund for Afghan children
when when he four days i believe it was
after the start of the war and do we
remember that day on sep tember 13th
when he said if you remember this the
sep tember 13 that the white at the oval
office when he's having a press
availability he's talking on the phone
to Tony Blair I think it is and he gets
asked a question about what's he feel
about the families and the children of
the victims and he says I'm uh I'm a
loving guy and he catching himself tear
comes to his eyes you remember this and
I'm a loving guy but they stops himself
he says and I'm somewhat however has got
a job to do and I intend to do it that
seems to me that represents what Bush
was doing in all of this where did he
start the war from where they tell us
the war was starting from not the Oval
Office but the treaty room interestingly
i think the treaty room where he said
where American presence have worked for
peace and out the back it's a beautiful
Sunday morning out in the back and I
believe actually you can see a kite
flying in the back and in the Jefferson
Memorial and it's all green and and
pretty and soft and yet he's telling us
we just declared war in Afghanistan he
sets up the fun for America for Afghan
children and ask all american children
to give a dollar
Laura Bush becomes the first first lady
in history deliver a full radio address
on november seventeenth after weeks of
radio addresses attacking afghanistan
and very militaristic Laura Bush comes
in with a softer let's think about the
children let's think about the women
under the Taliban in Afghanistan think
about the war itself as well in this
weird world that we had at that moment
where where b-52s were bombing the
bejesus out of the caves and in and the
the Taliban forces and then other planes
are flying over dropping eight that to
me is again its other representation if
you look at his rhetoric it's this
softer side this compassionate side as
well as as the harsh harsher side in
conclusion does all of this matter I
think it does it matters what presidents
say it matters how presidents act there
are Chiefs of Staff our chiefs of State
they are our symbolic leaders but beyond
that it matters because what presidents
say influence policy we have this
general worldview that you have this
great policy and then presidents say
these words about it in a reality quite
often presidents say words and then we
get a policy out of that so it matters
and we should think about you know
crisis will come up in the future like
this and it seems to me we should think
about what types of characteristics that
our presidents will hold that will allow
them to provide what i think in both
cases and you can argue about the the
you know Iraq and all that kind of stuff
now but I think in both cases
rhetorically FDR and george w bush did a
heck of a job symbolically as our chief
of state and let me let me stop there
and see in like a few minutes if there's
any questions or comments or arguments
from the floor
much of what you tried to do in your
speech I have my students do where we
evaluate both FDR and bush one of the
major differences that I see is that my
students can fully appreciate how their
grandparents needed to trust FDR not
knowing what was happening not having
nearly as much information in that time
as my students do now they could
appreciate their grandparents need for
trusting their commander-in-chief
unfortunately my 11th graders do not
trust mr. bush how do you account for
that difference in those two individuals
well I think part of it goes and you
make an excellent point about just
information and in a world where you
have limited information you have no
choice but to trust I mean you really
have to trust in that I think that's
part of it for sure it's also a part
when I try to make a point earlier that
I think FDR had eight years of bonding
with the American public eight years of
he does get it he does you know he's
doing the right thing for me and the
American people felt that way in this
depression so it's eight years of sort
of bonding in a crisis you don't have
that with Bush you just have that after
after nine nine eleven we also live it
seems to me a more partisan age than we
did then you have a shooting war at that
point as well and the constant reminders
of and this is a shooting war but it's
it's with the Japanese and the Germans
and the kind of rhetoric that I just
mentioned of FDR it's difficult not to
say we got it really we all understand
we have to really work hard kick butt
over there and and or they're coming
after sort of thing now it's you know
that sort of was the instant reaction
for the first few months when the first
let me remind you though that bush's
popularity last
longer than fdr's did by a long stretch
long stretch bushes his rally effect
after 911 is just ending now so they
might not trust in that way but Bush
ended up much more popular than that FDR
was the trusting maybe a bit different
we can talk about but Bush ends up 18
points i believe it was higher higher
jump than fdr's and then lasts well over
a year longer so it's you know it's sort
of a mixed bag on that good I would like
you to comment about what you think the
difference in the media between the time
that FDR was I was seven years old in
1942 and I distinctly remember the
fireside chats and everybody SAT around
their radio and listen to them and the
difference now in the the huge number of
media that we watch and the the effect
that has on on what we the American
people are are we getting are we more
confused with more information or are we
have we changed so much that information
overwhelms us it seems to me then some
some ways we often just say oh I'm so
little I can't do anything and I'm going
to tune out and actually that is what's
happening in the United States as the
voting but the whole effect of the media
difference when FDR was president and
Bush was president it's clear that we
are seems to me clear that we're over
saturated with the media our president
show up too much I mean this is really
even more of a problem for Clinton and
Bush didn't have this until nine eleven
then we'll 911 happen he's all over the
place and he continues that sort of more
visible pattern but FDR FDR was we
didn't have him in her face all the time
we didn't have him the fireside chat was
a special time because he wasn't on all
the time I didn't see him on the news
every night and you also had the the
media ethic I mean let's face it he
lived in a world where he was
handicapped he couldn't walk but the
merit but the media didn't tell the
American people that
and now it's every flaw it's every it's
just it's a much difficult much more
difficult job to see me being present
now than it was pre television age and
pre Watergate AIDS that's the other
moment when the when the press become
vicious anti-establishment whoever is in
there were going to tear them down where
FDR didn't have to deal with that so I
think the media is another very good
point say um I found the parallels
between FDR and President Bush very
interesting but in response to that dr.
Gregg my question for you is how do you
think the state of the country would be
different and the leadership would be
different had the votes been interpreted
differently and ghorban in office and
what I'm asking in essence is how much
of Bush's symbolic leadership of what
you speak can be chalked up to his
character as a man and how much of it is
just a response to the situation
excellent point it's excellent question
most political scientists deal with this
thing that I mentioned earlier called
the rally effect and if you don't know
what that means just when that when a
crisis happens they tend to think we
rally around the flag and the popular
the president goes up true that seems to
me doesn't fully answer the question
though for instance the question of why
Bush's pop bushes popularity went up to
the highest in history why it lasted
where every other rally in history ends
in a couple of months his lasted almost
two years during a time of economic
downturn these are this is this it seems
to me cannot be chopped up to chopped up
to it just happens because it's the
rally something's different happening
here and now what would happen with gore
I don't know I can't I could give you a
guess but it wouldn't be fair to give
you a guess on that and I don't know
it's a good quiet it's a great question
to think through and I don't know what
it would have been you will you focus
your remarks on both presidents talking
to the American people you thought at
all about the differences between the
way that each of the president's reached
out to the other nations in the time of
war no
I mean I can see where your obvious
question it's a great question too and I
just haven't thought of it do you have a
thought you want to opine well I mean
that one of one of the criticisms of
President Bush is that we we find
ourselves in a position was very
difficult now to go back to the nation's
that we more or less spurn I don't know
enough about FDR and how he handled that
same situation to to have an opinion but
well let me I don't know either but let
me let me end with sort of related
comment not quite related but i'll use
it to pretend this related anyway
because I said I'd do some differences
let me do one major difference and one
major difference is fdr's use of Pearl
Harbor and the Japanese attacks versus
pushes and that is what i discovered go
back two thousand one and remember okay
2001 it happens what happens six months
later have a ceremony at the White House
right what happened six months after
that on the one-year anniversary we have
a massive day of ceremonies right
commemorating 911 ending with his
standing in front of the Statue of
Liberty that beautiful backdrop of the
Statue of Liberty powerful backdrop Bush
goes through reminding the nation always
of 911 and what's happened and FDR not
only didn't do that but he absolutely
refused to do that and so this is a
difference here you can you can you can
talk about why that might be but he on
one-year anniversary of Pearl Harbor he
said nothing publicly zero nothing on
the second year anniversary of Pearl
Harbor he gave a communique about to
Winston Churchill are about a meeting
with Winston Churchill and he had with
the Turkish ambassador or something like
that no connection whatsoever and then
in 1943 which same here that one happens
Congress passes a bill that says sets up
December seventh as an armed forces
appreciation day forever commemorating
it what's but what's FDR do vetoes it he
vetoes it and says this is inappropriate
so there is a massive
between the Bush administration of the
way we are commemorating and continuing
to commemorate 911 though it was much
more subdued yesterday if you watch very
subdued in fact the most visible the
president wasn't seen to me was when he
walked out and he just silently stood in
prayer at the front of the White House
and turned around Cheney and him and the
first lady and Lynne Cheney and they
walked back in the White House and say a
word very dramatically downscaled from
last year but I should wrap up with that
and thank you all for for having me here
in the hollands teen center Grand Valley
State